Nabi Saleh: A tiny village in the
occupied West Bank that has been waging
a sustained, unarmed resistance movement
against Israel's military rule.
This is the birthplace of Ahed Tamimi, the Palestinian
teenager who confronted armed Israeli
soldiers in front of her house ...
and served eight months in prison.
Her slap reverberated around the world,
catapulting her into the international
spotlight as a symbol of Palestinian resistance.
In the days leading up to her release,
I came to Nabi Saleh to learn Ahed's backstory,
and to experience for myself
daily life in this village, which is
being choked by an illegal Israeli
settlement and which suffers regular
violence from the occupation forces. I
wanted to hear what lies ahead for the
young generation of Palestinians growing
up under an occupation with no end in sight.
We're in the Palestinian town of Nabi
Saleh, in the occupied West Bank, where
Ahed Tamimi grew up. And right across the
road over there is the illegal Israeli
settlement of Halamish. And the
presence of those settlers, and the many
soldiers deployed here to protect them,
has made life for villagers in Nabi Saleh a living hell.
These are regular scenes in Nabi Saleh. Israeli soldiers
firing tear gas, skunk water,
rubber-coated steel bullets, and even
live ammunition, while unarmed
Palestinians march carrying flags and
banners, and sometimes throwing stones.
For the past decade, the villagers have
led a popular nonviolent resistance
movement to protest the Israeli settlers'
creeping confiscation of their land and
resources. This resistance campaign began
in 2009, after settlers took control of a
natural spring that's owned by one of
the elders in the village. The Tamimi
family traces its roots back to Nabi
Saleh for hundreds of years. More than
500 people live here, most of them
extended family. Across the road, the
Israeli settlement of Halamish was
created in 1977. It's one of more than
200 settlements in the West Bank built
on occupied Palestinian land, in
violation of international law. Before
you can even enter Nabi Saleh, you have
to pass by the settlement and an army
base to protect it. An army observation
balloon with cameras monitors the
village at all times. International law
allows Palestinians to resist occupation,
even via armed struggle within the
bounds of the laws of armed conflict. The
villagers of Nabi Saleh have chosen a nonviolent path.
But the Army's response has been anything but nonviolent.
Ahed’s life changed on December 15, the day
her 15-year-old cousin, Mohammad, was shot
in the head at close range by an Israeli soldier.
His injuries were so severe, he had to be
put into a medically induced coma, and he
lost an entire part of his skull.
Hours after Mohammed
was shot, Ahed confronted two armed
soldiers in front of her family's house.
The incident was filmed and shared on
social media by her mother, Nariman,
who would later be arrested and charged
with incitement. Millions around the
world were captivated by the image of a
young girl showing no fear as she hits
out at heavily armed soldiers.
Four days after, Israeli soldiers came to
her house in the middle of the night and arrested her.
While filming around Nabi Saleh, we were stopped several times by various Israeli soldiers.
So they just told us that we're not allowed to film that either.
And we were stopped by a guard for the settlement.
What are we allowed to film?
– Not the settlements?
– OK. Is that a law?
– In the Torah. Oh OK, so we're following the law of the Torah so no filming the settlements.
– Don't photo.
OK, alright.
A few miles outside of Nabi Saleh, Israeli
soldiers threw a stun grenade at us for
filming around a checkpoint.
– OK, Alright. Put the camera down. I don't speak Hebrew, I'm an American jour–
OK, OK.
Like elsewhere in the West Bank,
childhood for the youth of Nabi Saleh
is anything but normal. For many here,
it's not a matter of if they'll get arrested, but when.
Because of that, the
adults in the village organize regular
training sessions where they simulate
the experience of getting arrested,
detained and interrogated to teach the
children their rights and what to expect.
During her hours-long interrogation, Ahed remained silent, refusing even to say her name.
As many as 700 Palestinian children under the age of 18 from the
occupied West Bank are prosecuted every
year through Israeli military courts.
They're not accompanied by a parent, and
are often interrogated without a lawyer
or being informed of their right to
silence. Over the last three years, the
Palestinian child prisoner population has doubled.
Ahed's first cousin, 11-year-old Samer, became known as "Spider-Man," because he regularly dressed up as his
favorite comic book hero during the
weekly marches. He liked how Spider-Man
helped people and thought wearing his
costume would give him special powers.
I asked him what happened to his eye.
There are so many remnants of tear gas and sound-bomb
canisters left behind by Israeli
soldiers, Samer's family hung them up in
front of the entrance of their home. His
mother, Manal, told me why.
Manal says she’s been injured countless
times during the villages protests – one
time even getting shot in the leg with a live bullet.
And she's been arrested
three times. The last time was during a
women's sit-in outside the military court at one of Israel's prisons, one week after Ahed was arrested.
Why did they hit you when you were
arrested the last time?
Just days after she was released,
Israeli soldiers arrested her teenage
son Mohammed from their home. And like Ahed's arrest, it happened in the middle of the night.
I asked Manal why they arrested him.
Stone-throwing is the most common charge levied against
Palestinian children and is punishable
by up to 20 years in prison under
Israeli military law. After being
arrested, children are taken to
interrogation, where they're often tied
at the hands and feet, denied food and
water, and are physically and verbally abused.
Manal says her son Mohammed's
interrogation was so severe, it nearly broke him.
Mohammad's brother Osama, who was
arrested 10 days after him, was forced to watch his brother's interrogation – a form of psychological torture.
How do you feel, as a mother, having two sons in Israeli prison right now?
Israel's occupation, which is more than half a century old and with no end in sight,
puts Palestinians in the West Bank under
Israeli military law and a system that
denies them the legal rights of citizens.
Israeli settlers living in the same
territory have full democratic rights
and are governed by Israeli civilian law.
That means a Palestinian and an Israeli
settler can commit the same exact crime,
but be tried in different courts, with
different outcomes. Under the military
court system, Palestinians face a
conviction rate higher than 99%.
This dual and discriminatory legal
system has been denounced by many in the
international community as exemplifying apartheid.
As part of the preparations
for Ahed and her mom's return home,
they're about to raise a Palestinian flag right now.
I wanted to visit their
home to see how the rest of the family
was doing – with half of its members
imprisoned by Israel. Ahed's older
brother, Waed. has also been in jail since
May, serving an 18-month sentence for
throwing stones. Her father, Bassem, is one
of the leaders of the grassroots
resistance here. He's been arrested by
Israel several times and was tortured in jail.
You guys filmed Ahed as she slapped
the soldier, and you decided to publish
the video knowing very well that she might be arrested she might go to prison. Why did you do that?
Knowing that she went to jail because of the video, do you regret publishing it?
You would do it again?
Why do you say that it's normal?
In the meantime, the emotional scars left on his children
are evident. Bassem says his son Mohammed,
nicknamed Abu Yazan, copes with the
absence of his mother, sister and brother
by telling himself that they're just
away on vacation.
He's in denial.
But that's not where the trauma
for these children ends. Earlier this
year, Samer witnessed his 21-year-old cousin,
Izz Al-din Tamimi, get shot and killed in
his backyard by an Israeli soldier.
The following footage is graphic.
Israeli soldiers left Izz bleeding for 30
minutes before eventually transferring
him to a military vehicle. Once there, he
was held for another 15 minutes without medical attention.
The soldiers then surrendered him to an
ambulance. But it was all too late.
The trauma that children like Samer
witness is even apparent in the games they play.
Ahed's story has cast a spotlight on a new generation of Palestinian youth – their plight, their
hopes and their increasing influence in
the resistance against Israel's rule
over them. It's a generation with less
loyalty to the different political
factions, and growing disenchantment with
the Palestinian Authority, whose security
forces have coordinated closely with
Israel for more than two decades.
What do you think Ahed's generation will
accomplish that your generation wasn't able to?
12-year-old Salam is Ahed's
youngest brother.
While Ahed's incarceration made
international headlines, it is not unique.
Last year, Israel arrested 1,467
Palestinian minors. And there are
currently around 60 Palestinian females
in Israeli prison, many of whom have
longer and harsher sentences than Ahed.
The lack of attention other prisoners
get is a reality that Ahed's own family
members acknowledge.
Ahed has captivated the world partly because she is a woman, she's a female –
As the hours count down for Ahed and her
mother's return home, the future for this
village and for the Palestinian people remains grim.
It's been almost a decade
since you guys started your marches and
protests. And during these past years
you've lost so many relatives – they've
lost their lives or they've been in jail. Do you think it was worth it, and was it the right strategy?
In part 2 of this series ...
This is total chaos right now.
Ahed Tamimi is released from prison in a chaotic and emotional day.
I sit down with the Palestinian teen icon to hear what's next for her.
Hey guys, it's Dena and that's life in Nabi Saleh.
Make sure you check out part 2 of this
series, which is the day of Ahed Tamimi's
release, and my one-on-one interview with
her. Please make sure to like and share
this video and subscribe to AJ+.